♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(CROWS CAW)
Easttown is a mixture
of a number of different towns
in Pennsylvania
around where I grew up,
and I wanted the show
to be about
a certain place in the world,
a certain group of people.
These people
have been born here.
They've been raised here,
and now they're raising
their children here.
KATE WINSLET: That sense
of history and shared history,
united history
that is very apparent
in this particular area
of Easttown
is quite unique I would say,
and-- and everyone knows
a little bit
about what
someone else is up to,
and there's always the sort of
resident, slightly annoying
character
Mare would have to deal with.
SPEAKER:
Mare? Mare, you out there?
Oh, you're here.
I'm here.
CRAIG ZOBEL: We shot primarily
in what I would call
an exurb of Philadelphia,
kind of like
the southwestern area
outside Chester County
and Delaware County,
and that really did inform
so much.
It was nice to kind of be
in a place
that felt like America,
and wasn't so specifically
a big city.
We wanted to make sure
that the vibe of the show
and the feeling of Easttown
was specific
in many different ways.
We did it through location.
We would try to pick a location
that was true to what
it really was
and not just
the most picturesque.
(HORN HONKS)
We would do it with costume.
Our costume designer
would constantly be texting me
pictures
from the Wawa convenience store,
just of people in the line.
JULIANNE NICHOLSON:
The clothes really all felt
lived in to me
and of that place.
For instance,
I mean, I had, I think,
a Dave Matthews concert T-shirt
and certain things that maybe
you won't even see on camera,
but those little details
for her
and the actors are important.
I wanted the show to have
a grittiness to it
and have an honesty to it,
to have a realness to it.
These are people that get up
every morning
and go to jobs that don't
necessarily love,
but yeah, they do it
out of a sense of duty.
So, I wanted to portray
these communities that exist
that don't often get any time
on the screen in a way
that was heroic and noble
and also really sympathetic.
MARE SHEEHAN: We're asking
parents if their child
might have seen something'.
Please come forward.
Every bit of information
helps at this point.
GUY PEARCE: What's beautiful
about this story
is that it isn't
just about the crime,
it isn't just about the mystery
and who's done it,
but it's about the families.
You have the opportunity
to sort of investigate
all the families
and see the effects
that the crime has had
and get involved
in everybody's personal stories
and see how they're interwoven.
So, there's something
kind of heightened, you know,
in the drama, I suppose,
when it is a small town.
You're pushin' everyone away.
Including you?
No, I won't let you.
WINSLET: The show is very much
about compassion and mercy
and looking out for your friends
and your neighbors,
and it's quite special
in that regard,
very moving in that regard.